what are the top three reasons a
filmmaker will be rejected by a film
festival well I think one his first
thing and something that was thinking
about this a little more is times
something that's not even the fault of
any filmmaker at all it's some festivals
and at times even we see it with ours is
there's a you have a story you're
telling that that's that's sort of
redundant in the sense that it's a
category that's very heavy in a certain
areas like a style storytelling right so
it can be sometimes dramas where there
might be a certain type of story sort of
heavy family drama that might be so
replicated by maybe ten other films or
maybe more that are telling some of the
very similar story now and that if that
happens as programmers we're looking to
program a diverse range of films and are
we gonna show you know four or five six
the same types of stories and films and
if we're only selecting four hundred or
thousands of films that's gonna be hard
to say yes to that so sometimes as they
no fault of any one's it's just more of
a situation of percentages and you're
telling a story that might happen to be
similar without getting too many details
of like specific story like a exact sex
story I'm not gonna like retell a story
but you know what I mean like like it
just it falls under something that that
you have we're seeing in this whole
submission pool like identical stories
essentially sometimes even very
identical to the point where if it's
something if some work of you know like
you know of missing the the exact
verbiage here but like when a filmmaker
takes a story that's like public domain
and remakes a story whether it's Stephen
King short or something like that right
and they tell that story you might see
for submissions of the same exact movie
which is kind of fascinating RS I were
like hey who did it better or did it
worse what worked they're all different
movies but they're the same story so now
you're seeing films they're literally
the same story so at that point who's
gonna make any are we gonna show all
four of them even if they're all great I
mean you it hard to say yes to that
we're now going to show the same movie
over and over and we've had it happen
we're actually two films are the same
films I've actually made it in the two
same stories with different types of
films we made different films made but
the same story so that can't happen as
rare but it has happened but most times
it's not gonna they're not gonna get in
like it's hard to say okay which
if they're all greater or maybe none get
in but what if one gets in now we're
gonna accept two more or another one
well generally speaking of the same
story now that's not something you can
control as a filmmaker how do you know
you made a film how do you know that
someone else made the same film how do
you know they submitted the photo you
wouldn't know that so that's not
something that you can actually control
so there's an element of controllability
with that then there's also the
percentages as I mentioned it we've went
from the early years twenty-three
hundred seventy five hundred thousand to
now you know we're talking five thousand
plus submissions same amount of spots
we're not increasing the festival to eat
hundreds Lots we're not going fourteen
fifteen days were ten days around four
hundred films are generally make you
give or take based on runtime and
everything and you know five programs a
day and this is and also within that we
have different categories so we have to
fill in the blanks of what can fit based
on genre need in style and things like
that family films evening type stuff you
know different styles for different
times and things so now the percentages
are shrinking how many films can make it
in and we fit in that criteria of all
these films so that is already
inherently a competitive situation we're
talking five to maybe ten percent of all
submissions that will generally
essentially get accepted
so now inherently that's already we're
saying potentially ninety percent may
not even make it and I've been talking
about scores I'm talking about anything
else as I have just the numbers there so
then that's already again an inherent
honest portrayal of the competitive
nature so there's that so and now I said
all that then we get into okay now
what's wrong then the next step is the
next thing we're looking at of course
isn't any of the potential flaws whether
it's technical stuff technical issues
that are you know whether it's just the
obvious things of poor jump cuts or you
know obviously boom mic and shots these
kind of obvious things any of those
things that's it that's like a sort of
automatic rejection of sorts basically
you were limiting yourself in that sense
just because of those those errors or
edits or issues so there's that and then
you get into okay how is the acting how
is the storytelling how is the writing
how is the Scimitar fee or the technical
aspects of the film you know if if some
of those are okay Vande some of them are
really poor and you're gonna have a
lower score you're just gonna get
rejected missed
going to make it you know and again
that's the standard base on we're
talking our festival at this time I
don't know other festivals have less
emissions maybe there's more slots or
different things that they have going on
but when you look at that at that aspect
of it those are there's some of those
elements that are for us it's sort of it
can it can make it sort of automatic
you're sort of rejecting yourself in
some sense if there's some of those
areas are flawed and then of course
technical stuff is off those things are
sort of automatic then you get into
after all that you know what are we
looking to program how is the
storytelling is it unique that's a big
thing like we're looking for at times
watching so many films and our review
team and myself watching so many films
it's always exciting and something
that's something that's desirable that
you know that a film and a story is very
you know whether it's outside the box or
just unique or different stands out in a
big way know now that can be a lot of
things whether it's just very whether
it's very graphic or whatever or
wherever whatever it's it's just
something unique style of storytelling
or its visually very different or
whatever that may mean but that that's a
big deal because that's gonna you look
in all these films and if something this
could arise at the top you'll equate
this I've never seen this before there
something is very unique and we've never
seen it before we've seen all these
films that's something that's obviously
gonna whale on our minds we're not gonna
forget that
so I guess we're long in the way of
saying just try not to be forgettable
you don't forget it we can make it
something that's just like wow everyone
watching that you walk away it's saying
why I can't believe that film it that
was amazing because you know there are
many stories that that are I guess
playing it safe you know where the
filmmaker storyteller is not really
trying to push boundaries we're not
trying to you know and not trying to do
something different they want to make
maybe it's just in those in the
filmmaking style you know maybe there's
a lot of two shots not trying to get
into any any too much can't now I know
this budget restraints and things of
course but within that you have to be
creative and show your style if it's not
how is that gonna stand out amongst the
whole crowd of all these films if you
don't your chances of being sucked at
that point become very very very low it
just it's just the numbers game is there
it's it's very difficult so yeah I think
it's a that's uh without talking
technical stuff the big thing is in
films are too
we're lack of a better word I guess
vanilla you're kind of shooting yourself
in the foot for us at least that's
definitely we've seen so many films if
nothing stands out about it how is it
going to be unforgettable for us if it's
not forgettable then we're just we're
probably gonna forget it in a sense
right so that's that's that's it that's
important you think people are taking
less risk or more risk in terms of the
storytelling aspect pushing boundaries
just be just sort of being these like
agent provocateurs like putting stuff
out there that's like whoa and some
people gonna be really offended by it or
do you think it's it's less so I think
yeah well that's always a are we to PC
yeah maybe I mean well I don't know we
it's tough to say because I I see a lot
of stuff that's not so I'd say no then
but then the same time there's a lot of
we're also living in this new age of
sort of being checked online PC culture
like don't say this don't say I don't do
this and it's just this this sort of of
course we know there's like this online
battle going on with all this stuff
whether it's cyber bullying or just
people just so the mob mentality of
jumping on people for certain things you
say the wrong thing and it's forget
about it and stuff like that so that
isn't really I still think that doesn't
play much into the film's I think people
are trying to really push boundaries
tell really great stories and and share
what they believe in and also show their
vision and style because again this is
also goes back to the beginning of what
it is Schwartz always were and still are
at some degree of course a calling card
you're trying to say hey look at me
world this is what I do this is what I
can do this is my ability I'm showing
you this in what you know what a
restraints I'm up against there's how
much money I have is what I can do
within this this what is this restraint
right like hey I got 10 grand is what I
got to make with it and I can make a
make a kick-ass film okay well that's
what you're trying to do so if you can I
do that you know you're making a you
know a seven minute you know short
that's just you know I don't know as a
drama that we've seen before we told a
certain story that's been done many
times by many filmmakers and there's
nothing original to it and there's no
new touch to it or anything else it's
like you're not gonna see many
acceptances at that point you know it's
like it's gonna so you really want to
see people take a chance whether it's
just something that's provocative or
something that's adventurous or just out
there or if it is political or something
that's trying to make a stance or a
stand or just you know make a big strong
point
you still got it you got to try to show
that but what you got try do it you know
and yeah yeah I mean look all that said
though some people do want to make the
film they want to make you have to make
your film you can't try to make
something and try to be someone you're
not so there's always that it was it was
is that but it's how you tell even the
symbols of stories how well you do it
visually and how it's how you showcase
your abilities is what it's about cause
we're trying to showcase what we feel
are the best films in the world that's
the goal that's the idea so if it
doesn't fall under that or doesn't feel
like it it belongs in that or it's that
exciting then why are we gonna put all
of our chips on it and really push it
all forward and say this is what we have
to showcase this has to be accepted and
there's other ones not to get rejected
you take that place of all the other
films yeah it's like you almost there's
like you commit to like make it say why
like convince us so that's that's you
know that's part of it yeah there was
one film that I just I can still see it
to this day as it was about a woman who
had been raped and she ended up having a
child and she loved that child and the
child finds out that it's a product of
rape but I mean now that film was
unbelievable and I realized that some
people be very scared to do that yeah
especially in today but I mean to me I
thought that was an amazing yeah I know
you guys have shown some very you know
things that really push boundary but but
there's reasons for that and they're
really amazing so I ya know and it's
also for us has been a joy of like we
we're in a position with this and I've
said it before a week and we have the
opportunity to dictate what we want to
do with the festival with the style with
with everything with parties events
whatever part of the plan of the event
or whatever we show whatever it gets
screen it's is exciting to have
obviously a saying something in this
world right where we can say this is
what we feel is the best way to do this
is how we and we believe in this and we
can do that so with that we obviously
have opportunity and and and also
responsibility to try to do the best we
can with it
and if we're giving a stamp of approval
we're sort of trying to be as many
festivals believed to be gatekeepers are
saying this is what we need to show you
as an audience this is what you need to
pay attention to Hollywood look at these
filmmakers in these films because this
is what what we believe are the best the
best is well believed you need to look
at this is the film these are the films
you need to pay attention to that's what
we're doing you're shining a light on
these films that's the obviously we're
doing you're saying these ones come take
a look at these other ones didn't quite
make it Fraser reasons or whatever but
this is
we believe in strong you have to
obviously come see these movies so you
know that's a responsibility though we
also have to take serious and I just
throw up anything on screen just because
we you know feel like we owe someone
something or something that's just not
you know that's not what that's about
but you know I think when the the more
films and filmmakers are pushing those
boundaries what a lot of festivals are
are doing like Sundance and they program
a lot of stuff that you'll see over the
years as also push boundaries been very
you know unique and aggressive in their
storytelling their styles and and not
pulling back or holding back for fear of
what people react to it what they'd say
you know that's you know especially if
there's something to see the voice you
want to really share what you have the
saying you believe in it doesn't make
sense to be restrained or pull back just
based on fear of reaction or what people
might think of you or something that's
not gonna work and if you do that your
your your chances of being something
that many festivals or any are very low
at that point so it's you know yeah yes
you guys to where you got to tell but
that also means if it is more of a film
that doesn't require that kind of it's
not a provocative story or things like
that it can be more of a simple kid's
film or somebody that's fine but if it's
the opposite and supposed to be quite
this very provocative story and things
don't also pull the curtain back or pull
back a bit you know like it's I think of
a quote that a lot recently it was
dealing with that same subject of like
you know when it came to a film that was
very it was it was telling a war story
and they were saying there was
responsibility to not you know pull back
on how aggressive an awful that is is if
you're not showing what that really is
that you're doing that disservice the
people think oh this is okay this is
this is not that bad you know you can't
walk away feeling that way that's not
what we should be portraying as a
situation they're showing what it means
to be in war war is violent awful and
terrible and sad to make that feel like
it's not you know that's a disservice so
that's something that I think people
should really keep in mind and that's
something I've always kind of thought of
when I think back to that quote and
forgive I can actually member the exact
quote
and so I'm paraphrasing someone of
something I saw recently and I remember
I stuck with me and a documentary was
watching it was it's very important to
show how
how awful things like that can be and if
you're telling that story not telling
the pc way you know to make sure it is
what it's supposed to be and it is also
aggressive and things like that or
whether it is violence or sad or
depressing not make it less depressing
you mentioned the thing about rape and
then like don't make that be something
that's like not awful or sad like make
it feel like it's just okay or just
that's then that's just don't told to
service anyone has ever been a victim of
anything like that's you know it's very
important to not have that be the case
and so yeah as long when the answer is
basically yeah I just make sure to you
guys go all the way ya know and and the
filmmaker spoke afterwards and you know
they gave a very I won't go into too
much hopefully we can put a link to it
in this video below but I mean it was it
was amazingly done and and they talked
about it and I remember I just went up
to the filmmaker afterward and just you
know thank them because it was just it
was an incredible story and although
they were trying to show that this this
mother loved this child you know they
had to go to certain places that might
make certain people a little bit
uncommon and challenging for those
actors and one involving the project and
that's right but that's you know
anything we're telling this is you know
it needs to be that and that's those
deciding when you see that it's for us
exciting we're like well wait while we
have a chance to actually show this and
let the story be told and give it sort
of a life if it's a role premiere like
well we got the shows with first time
like the audience can see this now and
this is the work they put in and the
chance they take in an hour you get to
showcase that that's you know it's
pretty cool so that's obviously
something that we were able to do here
this is part of the blessing to be able
to do this this work is they showcase
films like that you know give them the
chance or they're there or that's the
first chance or their only chance or
whatever or if he isn't the shown in the
movie 20 times already in we're like the
twenty first screening okay it's great
but we're getting a chance to show it to
our audience and another audience can
see it again and that's that's awesome
so that's something we're obviously
don't take we're ready
you